there you go up close and [ __ ] with a
camera guy good morning today we're
going to San Francisco uber is here got
a hurry up forgot something
alright let's go your brothers are
coming alone Alex please
we made it to San Francisco I don't know
how far away we are to the actual city
it's all fancy
probably should not be doing this
all right we're in San Francisco and I
think we already are stuck in the
tourist area there's so many people Hey
what they were freaking out they're
still yelling we can't seem to find a
place to eat all the other restaurants
were like 40-minute wait I'm done I'm
done already San Francisco you did it no
one in the restaurant okay great
man I love San Francisco so far it's the
best place
yes sit down
I'm sure it'll be better soon but so far
it's been pretty [ __ ]
I think I was filling the Hunger anger
maybe a little bit we're going on
Alcatraz tour maybe that will be better
okay great wait is this for real
28 you telling me in seven days we can
go oh that's awesome
I love summer this go this is such a
great city [ __ ] love this place
well this is like the same thing anyway
so that's good it's almost like I'm
there
look I can almost touch it wow what do
we do now have you done the go cars here
ah have you tried the go cars yeah is
are they fun oh yeah this'll made for
day city was I at 14 for it oh really
yeah I know a minute how much you want
to bet they're so low yes okay y'all
ready like in a photo not sure ready
we were literally the last people to get
one
we've been unlucky all the day so I
guess we got a little bit of luck
finally yes I have no idea if we will
make it out alive but we will try
for something
here great cool beats
a lot of stuff going on no I will get so
sunburned today I have no sunscreen I'm
fine it's called I'm gonna regret this
these people must be Swedish that Dargis
definitely Swedish my says trying so
hard they again
you want what next up I don't know where
but let's keep going so you leave me
what a service thank you very much right
as Crissy Field in 1998 massive
restoration project was undertaken here
when completed in 2001 ok best parking
ever there you go up close and chin with
a camera guy I don't trust the camera
there's Alcatraz right there really cool
I'm glad we done like this tour is so
touristy but it's pretty cool it's a low
Sun that's it
chop-chop I can never get in the car
my pants are too tight nailed it
damn that's a pretty epic view Wow look
at that loser
my god what a loser all right that's
another the city's crazy
electric I'm good
houston we got a problem
Oh seriously
let's keep going I'm not allowed to vlog
while driving home again so cool for it
it doesn't feel like California this
area is so pretty I think we're in the
celebrity area we have to be quiet here
oops
another amazing parking this Jordan
Imran ah I'm a leg I can't get out this
car we saw this and we were like we have
to this is gorgeous
I've seen this before
it's really stunning in person oh my god
there sucks
before you go it
so pretty
where's my shits ever there what are you
doing we're supposed to have the car for
two hours I think we spend two and a
half already yeah we should yeah we
should probably go I was so pissed by
this start of the day and I hated San
Francisco for a while but it's really
beautiful oh my foot thank you what the
[ __ ] what the hell is is 350 cars this
is not a street this is a left Mario
Kart Jesus Christ yes music we're super
late and super lost in the middle of the
city
oh great we fin it we came back we got
so lost hey we made it back oh great
will you not charge us right all right
brah did you like that or they gonna
love get okay we're heading back to the
hotel and then we're probably going out
for dinner the light is so cool
oh my space my name is dragon fighter 69
of my space
all right we're going in for dinner I
hope they have a table for us I don't
think so
well it was full finding a place to eat
in San Francisco is like the biggest
struggle ever apparently all right Sam
number two we can do this I promise
come on good night uh hey see you
tomorrow
thanks for watching another blog wrong
okay brofist